hey everyone we have a special episode
with andrew wilkinson
um i'm gonna tell you about him in a
second i think you're gonna like this
episode but
i have a huge favor so look shawn and i
we spent a ton of time preparing for
this podcast
uh like hours tens of hours a week uh 20
30 hours a week
preparing just for these two episodes
and i know it sounds like we're
kind of shooting the [__] and in a way
we are but we actually work so hard at
it
and i need a favor from you i'm begging
you please
leave us a review in itunes so if you're
listening to this on spotify
just click click your podcast app or
whatever it's called an android
and go to the itunes store and just
leave us a review click five stars and
just click like
i really like it or leave one star and
be like hey sam you suck
whatever but we need reviews and the
reason why
we need reviews is we go higher up in
the charts and the higher up in the
charts we go
the more listeners we get and the more
listeners we get the more
ad revenue or hubspot money we can make
which we can then put back into the show
and do more stuff if you've noticed
we've hired a team to create videos
we've done that because we're getting
we've been getting more views and we're
able to
invest more into this podcast um and we
want to do more stuff we actually want
to go on a live tour this summer
and we want to come to you we'll do it
for free um but we need to
get more listeners and the easiest way
to do that is just to leave a review i
know you hear a lot of
pockets saying do this and most of you
are just like kind of skip to this part
but
for real do it in fact if you do do it
and you send me an email sam at
thehustle.com or
uh i prefer you do this you tweet at me
the sampar
and take a screenshot of your
review and make sure i see it and i'm
going to call
all of you out everyone who leaves a
review i'm going to call you out
um i'll i'll either do it on twitter
i'll do this on the podcast but i'm
going to recognize you for doing it so
please
make that happen uh i have a feeling
that this podcast is going to get
listened by a lot of people
and so um get that in
sooner rather than later so i don't miss
it but go ahead do that
uh and it'll be a really big deal for us
so leave a review please
now let's talk about today's episode so
today we have andrew wilkinson andrew
wilkinson
is a good friend of ours he's really
interesting because
he does everything so basically andrew
started with this
design agency called metalab he grew
metalab to like 50 million dollars in
revenue
out of based out of canada and it was
very profitable something like 20 30
million dollars of profit on like 50
million dollars in sales something like
that
and using that profit he went and bought
a variety of companies and
at this point they owned like 20
different companies uh ranging from a
bakery up to different types of uh
software so he just bought this company
called girlboss
he uh uh bought a few others and on this
podcast we're going to talk about what
companies he's buying and why he's
buying them
he's also done a few interesting things
like you ever read about how someone
bought
a lunch with with warren buffett uh well
he did that with a bunch of different
investors
and that's really fascinating so give
the episode a listen uh
look up andrew wilkinson and uh he's on
twitter he's very active if you tweet at
him he'll reply
if you tweet at me thus sampar i'll
reply as well
uh sean did not make this episode
because sean has a
four-week-year-old baby so that's why
we're doing some of these extra episodes
about them
but please leave us a review let me know
what you think
abreu how did you rate this episode i
forget what you you gave it
i think this was definitely in the a's
we we covered a lot of ground a bunch of
stuff
andrew brought the heat as always a
bunch of opportunities i think
everyone's gonna like it
hey today's episode is an a uh
that's good i'll take it what was your
favorite part uh he had a ton of stuff
on how he grows his network andrew's
super smart he has like a bunch of
billionaire friends and
he kind of lays out his strategy of
meeting all these people
and i think that's applicable to just
about anybody listening
all right well everyone give it a listen
please please please
give us a review i'm telling you i'll
owe you big time and it actually makes a
huge difference and me and sean we read
every review and we actually talk about
all of them we'll say
is this person right should we keep
doing this or this guy uh tease us for
doing xyz should we actually stop doing
that what should we do
so we read all of them leave us review
uh listen up
see you i feel like i can rule the world
i know i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back all right what's going on
not too much man beautiful day here in
victoria what about you
uh nothing we uh i've been
spending all my time on this podcast
trying to make it huge we've got some
really cool stuff planned and i'm
excited to see it work out
yeah i feel like you guys are really
ramping up there's a new episode in my
inbox like every single day
well what's yes it's going really well
and we did the math and we're like if it
grows
if if the last 16 months repeats itself
um it'll be we'll be at a million
downloads a month
by like uh decemberish uh which is fine
which is great
but figuring out how to like hack this
has been really hard
and so we're just trying to figure out
how to make it huge well what's hubspot
what's their goal
their goal so the hubspot has a bunch of
cool stuff uh that they're launching
basically like a bunch
a bunch of content initiatives including
podcasts
and their goal is to reach uh
a certain number like i don't remember
the exact number but they say like how
do we get to 100 million monthly
uh newsletter reads
podcast lessons things like that so 100
million monthly audience of mine and
they've just done the math
on you know if five percent of those
people convert into hubspot
customers then it makes it pays back the
acquisition or something
why no that's across that 100 million
that 100 million is across all their
content
um it's not just the hustle and the
hustle
right now the hustle we have close to 2
million monthly or 2 million
subscribers of which like 50 60 open
rate so that's
adds to the 100 million um
and so this podcast accounts for right
now 400 500 000
eventually it'll be a million a month
and then if they have other podcasts
that's another let's say 10 million
so then we're at 50 million and then
where's the other 50 million going to
come from and so
uh that's kind of how they're doing the
math
like how does it change for you going
from like
staring at your p l every month looking
at the bank account
freaking out about invoices not getting
paid to suddenly going oh i don't have
to do that i just have to focus on
growing the audience
yeah so it's pretty great like a lot of
people hubspot never said this but a lot
of people
were like man you're only going to work
there for like a few months or a year
and then you're going to want to bail
and frankly i'm having a great time um
like i think i'm meant to start a
company again
and i this is my first job i've ever had
but it's been really great and i can see
myself doing this for a little while
uh because it's awesome like and like
let's like talk about the obvious which
is like i made money for myself
so like i can relax a little bit i uh
it's not
as hard like i'm working a lot long
hours but it's not as hard because if i
fail or screw up
like i'm not going to like cost people
their jobs do you know what i mean like
if i make it wrong decision
i'm not necessarily going to lose a lot
a significant amount of money or
someone's gonna have to be fired because
i can't make payroll so that
the lack of stress is so good have you
ever have you noticed have you noticed
like your cortisol levels are dropping
and you're just more chill
interesting dude i'm like never i've
never felt that
i've never felt that because i've always
had there's always been so many
different businesses that
anytime we've sold one i've been
neglecting another one
for a year and then that blows up and i
get all stressed out so it's been
i've been thinking about this a lot but
i've been going from stress to stress
for and like seven or eight years
probably since we sold our our one of
our first companies
and uh i've been thinking lately like
i'm going like holy crap i gotta
de-stress and that sounds really nice to
not have to
think about any of that stuff well the
way i described it so
what i describe when i like uh
moved out to san francisco and like put
by stake in the ground like all right
i'm gonna figure this out
i felt like i'd been living with poor
eyesight and i finally put glasses on
and i'm like oh this is the world like
i could do anything i could do this i
could finally see now
after selling it's like a different put
my glasses on and realize i had poor
eyesight
where i'm like to my wife now i'm like
oh my gosh is this how you feel all the
time
like you don't have to worry about x y
and z what a crazy feeling this is
actually quite nice now
i want to put that stress level back on
again eventually but it's nice having
that break
um and what i think about with you is
i'm
envious of what you have in some regards
right i think we're always envious of
of other people especially our friends
i'm envious that you've built this
huge awesome empire that you own nearly
all of it that you have virtually
all the control that's very most people
envy you because of that
but i also think to myself wow andrew
also hasn't
chilled probably for a minute and that's
definitely the downsides
and so like in order to be the best you
definitely got to wear that which you
are
you have to worry uh carry that worry
backpack
a fair bit oh yeah it's crazy and it's
so funny like the numbers just get
bigger right so it's like i
you know i i remember in like 2012 one
time we like
did payroll we didn't have enough money
and like my business partner literally
lent me money out of his personal
account
to close payroll right so we've been at
that level of stress
and you know i never feel that now you
know we have enough money to go for
years or whatever
it's a very different thing but there's
still that feeling of like oh [__]
there's like 600 700 people relying on
me
to pay for their meal ticket every
single month um
and there's just constantly people
problems right so
yeah i've got like you know a lot of
control and
buck stops with me and you know a lot of
the things that people might envy
but at the same time like we've got 30
plus companies and there's always a
problem to think about or whatever
and i'm realizing i'm just constantly i
think i'm addicted to cortisol and
stress
and this year has been extra difficult
because
what i used to do is i'd work at a cafe
i'd like wake up like
pounding stress cortisol i'd be all
pumped up i'd do like three or four
hours of focused work get all the stuff
i need to get done
but then i'd go work at a cafe and my
buddies would show up and we'd start
shooting the [__] and go for a walk
and play tennis and just just kind of
half off and now with covet
it's like i'm in a house from 8 30 in
the morning until five
and then i go see my kids and it's crazy
that
um just the importance of like
distraction you don't get that like
right now working remotely in a house
you just don't get those moments
uh the automatic breaks and stuff and so
i'm realizing like man if i'm left on my
own devices
i'll i'll just stress to the nth degree
and just keep working
do you think and this was the last
question i asked about this because i
think i always try to be self-aware
where it's like oh a bunch of dudes
complaining about
[__] that maybe like is it like it's
right yeah well my reply to that is it
is a great problem it's
but great problems are still problems
first world problems are still problems
but they are first of all problems
but um do you think that it will ever
get
not or ever not be stressful like you
know we you talked about dan gilbert
last time this
uh billionaire guy who's got all this
stuff going on you said that he was
pretty calm and
present do you think that even a guy
like him who
kind of has it all or i mean people
think you and i have it all i imagine
but
as a guy like him who we think has it
all do you think that they still
stress i think i think it's it's
interesting i think dan's probably
really stressed out or at least was
because he has so many different things
that he's responsible for
where if he doesn't intervene it messes
up there's different versions of really
successful people though think about it
like
is someone who runs a private equity
firm where
they have this big pool of capital they
oversee and
they just buy businesses and they
oversee them or whatever
or or someone who like a hedge fund
manager who buys stocks right
you can have 20 employees you invest in
apple and all these companies
and at the end of the day apple does
well or it doesn't and you don't
influence that right i think
the number of things you influence is
what causes the stress
and i think in our business we we go oh
man if i'm not scanning the sky
for you know issues in all of our
businesses
we could lose something or mess up and
um
i don't know it's a it's a double-edged
sword because think about like
think about like your parents or old
people and like they get upset about
like oh the neighbor moved in
who you know doesn't want to water their
lawn
or someone's dog keeps pooping on their
front step or whatever it is
that stresses them out as much as you
and i get stressed out about business
stuff
so i think everyone's programmed to be
stressed and i think it's more about
what tools you have to distract yourself
from the stress
and if you've got a lot of those then
you're happy okay
so let's work here's the tool that we're
going to de-stress you perfect segway
so for the first topic today we are
going to talk about things that both you
and i have invested in
most of them are going to be things that
you've invested in and we're going to
span
we have one two three four five six okay
we're going to spend about three to five
minutes depending on how interesting
they are
where each other whoever listed it on
here will say what it is and why it's
interesting
and then i want to comment and tell you
what i would do if i was you and you and
vice versa
um but i want to hear your intel or your
your behind-the-scenes look as to why
you are investing in this
and why it might not work and why it
will work like why it could work and so
uh does that sound good
yeah sounds great all right the first
one you bought this company who
we've had sophia omarosa on the podcast
you bought her old company called
girlboss is it just girlboss.com is that
the url girlboss.com yeah
and what is it so girlboss is like a
like a media company for women so sophia
started it about
six years ago and built up this massive
following
started doing amazing events podcasts uh
built like a social network and she
i met her when she was first starting it
and she'd
um done nasty gal which was like this
big flame out where she built a really
amazing business was doing 30 million
dollars a year
doing online e-commerce selling or used
clothes
doing really really well right she
didn't need the money and she ended up
raising from venture to take a little
bit of money off the table
and then the venture investors got in
and we're like hey you got to 20x this
go take risks start retail stores she
starts the retail stores and it all
blows up
a really horrible story where she had a
good thing and then she
risked it and then it blew up and so she
was fresh off of that and she said look
i'm starting this company girl boss
i think i want to bootstrap it and and
you know i might raise a little tiny
round but i'm not going to raise venture
again
and so we ended up investing um and
following along
and she ended up raising venture again i
don't know what it was specifically i
think she saw
like a bigger opportunity and decided to
do it and the terms were great
um but so she raised venture and
decided to build like you know all this
stuff like a social network for women
building an app all these really
expensive r d projects
um and it got to a point where um it
just wasn't working and it wasn't
venture scale
and so she sold it to these guys
attention capital
uh in new york and they like they're uh
joe and uh nick right i think they're
yeah they're
like guys and they
yeah they they basically uh they they
focused on the event business they had
all these massive contracts
that were booked and then coveted hit
and they just got themselves into a
pickle where
they just couldn't the numbers didn't
make sense they were burning too much
money they lost all these contracts
and so they nudged me and said hey would
you be interested in buying this
and i said look i i i will buy it only
if i can just buy the assets
because we looked it and we said hey
they've got two million social followers
they've got a huge newsletter
all the piece they've got a massive
podcast feed all the pieces are there
but the cost structure um was venture
right so like they had you know a big p
l they had a ton of employees and we
looked at we went okay what if this
company had five employees
could you run it with five employees and
is that how many you have now
uh now now i think there's maybe seven
or eight or something like that but we
started with basically
you know one person doing newsletter one
person doing podcast one person doing
social
and then we just said as we sell more
ads we'll hire more people
and we ran it like a bootstrap business
and so that's what we've been doing
um and i think you know sophia uh was
pretty nervous when we bought it right
she's like don't embarrass me
uh you know make sure you hire the right
people and so we worked uh
you know in close partnership with her
and she's actually been really stoked
about what we've been doing so that's
been
awesome yeah i just uh you just you just
announced a new ceo i think you hired me
yeah
totally um so okay so okay
can you talk about any of the like the
size these two million subscribers
two million social followers how many
email subscribers
uh about 250 000 so i can't share the
the acquisition price that's fine um
but it was it was uh you know it was
let's say let's say i i felt it was a
value
investment based on the social followers
but if you looked at it on a p
l basis it was like holy crap this is a
mess right because they've been losing a
lot of money
okay what would you be happy with this
company in two years
um like how much monthly revenue yeah
what's cool about it is
when we when we buy a business uh we're
generally going
you know if we're wrong about all the
big opportunities
and we're only right about just base
hits so like
hey you know we've got 250 000
newsletter subscribers
can we sell 40 or 50 000 a month of ads
on that
if we do that we've got a good little
business and then if we do that on the
podcast we've got
a really good little business and then
if we do that on social
again it's bigger and bigger and bigger
it doesn't need to be huge
based on the price we paid it could do
three million bucks a year
in revenue and be an amazing business
and give us a good return
i think it's a 20 or 30 or 50 million
dollar a year business
once we kind of do the events we've been
thinking about
you know all sorts of opportunities
within the business um
but uh what i like about it is you know
if we don't do well
if we don't grow it into a huge company
we'll still we'll still do just fine
so i agree with that assessment i
actually think that so long as you're
mildly competent which you are uh
the worst case scenario is is two
million dollars a year i would say 160
a month yeah based off of a quarter of a
million email subscribers
two million um social followers
now it won't wouldn't exactly be
exciting or it wouldn't be the most fun
thing and that would be uh uh like if
that was the worst case scenario it'd be
like man we really mis missed the mark
on this but
you're not going to go out of business
and you're probably not going to lose
which is pretty good so
i actually agree with that uh assessment
i think that
if in 10 years if you were at 30 million
a year in revenue i wouldn't be
surprised it would probably be
it would probably be 15 uh
it'd probably be 20 million dollars a
year in advertising
and 10 million dollars a year in uh
user revenue so ticket sales more likely
than not i don't know if you would be
able to get subscriptions to this maybe
i actually do think that there's
i know a few uh people who have uh
female focused communities and they do
like three million dollars a year in
revenue yeah
i'm seeing like much smaller uh
communities doing way higher revenue
like we've looked at a lot of stuff for
m a like for even for girl boss
and uh there's there's definitely some
people doing really really well with
small communities
so the way i'm kind of feeling right now
like everything i look at
um and we're i don't know if people how
familiar they are with our structure but
we mostly buy majority control of
businesses and usually we're buying them
from founders
and then off the side of our desk we
also do a little bit of venture
investing maybe like two or three
million dollars a year we've got an
angelus rolling fund
for another i think 11 million or
something like that um
so my world is generally buying 11
million dollar
what hold on you have an 11 million
dollar rolling phone yeah
that's crazy right yeah we were it was
insane we
literally were like we tweeted it out as
like an afterthought and we raised it in
like four hours it was totally insane 11
million
yeah i think we're one of the biggest
ones i think so
i think that um you might be like the
second or third biggest i think i heard
of a 16 million dollar one but you might
you guys might be number one
you might actually size it up because it
you can it's limited just by the number
of people and if you have
uh there's no amount so if someone wants
to do five million bucks they can do
that
um so there's some people who are
looking at more uh
we've got uh angelus doing it they
administer everything and then all right
who's this
well i i decide right so basically i
already make
probably one one or two venture
investments a month
and it's usually like you know a friend
of mine emails me and says hey i'm
starting a company or
one of our agencies is working with a
company that we think is cool or
something and i just go
okay well i'll put in a hundred grand
and now instead of putting in a hundred
grand i put in 500 or a million via the
rolling fund
and i just invest my personal money into
the rolling fund um
so anyway so so we do venture investing
i look at that as like a hobby it's kind
of like roulette right it's just betting
on friends having fun
looking at companies um what i'm seeing
in venture is absolutely insane so i've
seen companies of
um with with a founder who's a
first-time founder
with an idea and they're raising in a 40
million dollar pre
valuation right like just totally crazy
stuff and in the
private market you know there's all this
crazy just endless money
and low interest rates and stuff and
almost everything we look at is just bit
up
like crazy like to the point where we
look at it and we go i don't see
any world even if everything goes right
where we can make our money back at this
price
and so for most of this year we've
basically just been sitting on our hands
and waiting um and trying to find hidden
value
and what i the way i think about hidden
value is like kind of like girl boss
where
you look at the p l and it looks like uh
you know oh whoa this is losing a lot of
money
i don't know how to value this but you
look at it and go under our
ownership what can this do and you make
a new p l in your head where you're like
oh i actually need five people
my only costs aws and mailchimp and
stuff
and so we've been doing a bunch of that
um and then
really uh we've just been kind of
sitting and waiting and getting creative
right and i'll talk about this guy henry
singleton later
we really are just trying to um you know
issue stock when it's highly valued and
buy stuff back when it's cheap
and so we've been looking across our
portfolio and just going like how can we
do
m a with our stock or how can we buy
cheap businesses and bolt them in that
people don't understand but it's it's
crazy out there right now
what okay but to play devil's advocate
and this is something that i'm playing
with in my head of like what do i stand
for what's going to be my
principles for investing and i haven't
settled on what those are yet although i
have some guiding principles they're not
solidified entirely
and a good friend of mine andreessen
horowitz said
don't worry too much about valuation
because
whatever's hot will continue to be hot
and you're gonna
like a lot of times the valuations
looking back will
be like oh that was cheap but then in
the middle of it it always appears to be
expensive but the real winners
it won't matter that much of course his
lens through to looking at that is quite
narrow
albeit effective but narrow but what's
your take on that
well i think i'm assuming andrew chen
because i know you're friends with him
um i think they're amazing investors the
some of the best in venture
i think the hard part is um you know if
you'd taken that same approach in 1999
it'd be really hard to be a winner right
because you see the same kind of stuff
happening where
uh historically i think we're at an
all-time high in terms of just like
pre-money valuations
but back then i mean there was companies
that were pre-revenue
selling for billions of dollars and all
the same crazy stuff and the problem is
that
within that haystack there's an amazon
right
or an ebay or a google but you just
don't know which one they are
and so i think if you were to go out and
index and buy a hundred random startups
in 1999
you'd probably lose money and i'd argue
you'd probably lose money today if you
went out and you indexed and i to me
the only way i'll bet on a someone um at
a high valuation
is if i know that they're a proven
operator like if they're a founder
who's done really well historically and
i have a lot of trust and think they're
amazingly smart
i don't worry too much about evaluation
but dude some of the stuff i'm seeing is
just wacky
just crazy crazy stuff is there one
thing
that you're seeing that interests you a
ton that
you've had the chance to invest in or uh
you passed on but you still think it's
quite amazing so
you're saying that like you've seen i
and i have two like ideas
from people who don't know what they're
doing or at least you don't know if they
know what they're doing and they're
these huge valuations
is there anything that you've seen
lately where you're like oh my gosh this
thing
potentially could be the coolest thing
i've ever seen
well i think if there's one thing i've
learned over the last 10 years it's
when you see something and you get lit
up about it ignore the valuation and
just invest right like it's like
there's lots of companies that i was
super excited about but i was like oh
i'm a value investor i'm not going to
you know do this on these terms what and
i should have i mean i got i've got the
ultimate
like anti-portfolio of you know coinbase
and uh slack and you know all sorts of
other stuff i mean
running an agency in silicon valley for
10 years like you just get you see all
sorts of stuff right
they turns out to be um big um
i i think the most thing the thing i'm
most excited about and nervous about
at the same time right now is like
crypto stuff and there's a company i saw
recently that i i didn't get the
opportunity to invest in but i think is
genius
so the crazy thing about crypto is
like at least theoretically um
historically if you are a member of
a website like reddit let's say and
you're an early user
let's say you're the first hundred users
have read it and you built it into
something
you actually derive no value right you
don't get paid you're like a wicked
wikipedia contributor and then reddit
makes billions of dollars
i know where you're going with this one
for the first time ever
i could start up andrew reddit and i
could say hey
all the people who move over from reddit
based on the number of followers you
have or whatever your rankings are
i'm going to issue coin in andrew reddit
and
as everyone moves over and posts more
you become more valuable kind of like
the big cloud thing right now big
cloud's kind of
whatever bs but i think for the first
time
social networks and network effects are
actually vulnerable to this
and one of the one of the businesses i
saw that i thought was fascinating was
a company called braintrust and what
they've done is they've
basically created a really nice upwork
so it's like uh you go to the website it
looks like a really well designed
version of
gabe is this gabe yes i know gabe
i uh
uh a year ago when he was about to
launch this and he told me all about it
because he was hiring a content person
um yeah i have not checked in on this
okay so
so i don't know what he was doing a year
ago but basically you go to this website
and it looks like um
you know up work it's like hey hire
contractors for design and development
whatever you need
but then it says no fees and i was like
well how the hell do they have no fees
that's crazy because upwork charges like
five or ten percent of all the projects
and what they do very quietly is they
have a coin
and they have a brain trust coin and
they have people who uh their job is to
basically be a project manager on there
those people get paid in the coin all
the transactions occur in the coin
so as you it's almost like if uber had
issued a coin to all their early drivers
and then as they participate in the
network they get rich and so they don't
go to lyft because they're already rich
in uber coin right and so it creates
this lock in
and it aligns incentives and before it
was always this thing where it's like
labor versus capital
and this is the first time it's all
aligned it's all
um you know very theoretical and early
and i don't know whether it's a good
time to invest right now
but it's obviously the future to me
interesting and so let's
talk about this so for the listeners the
guy who started this his name is uh
gabe what's his last name asta osteokote
uh he's got a two he's got two last
names him and his wife they've like
hyphenated it so i forget his full name
anyway he started a company called luna
ostaseki
or something yes yes yes um he started
this thing
called cal i forget what it was called
cal tech or no not uh something um where
it was like a lead gen
site for like roofers and uh
home services and it grew to like 30
million dollars a year in revenue
um i don't know how but in some way he
cashed out maybe his partners
bought him out or something like that
and he started this thing
brain trust about 18 months ago i think
and so
i actually will would email him after
this and being like
hey what's going on uh you raisin
because
this is really cool um i think i agree
with you this is really cool and he's a
very proven entrepreneur
now the thing i get nervous about when
it comes to people like him
is that will they be hungry enough to
make it big
i get nervous about that do you i don't
really think too much about that because
i think we all know like
you know you you're gonna have this exit
and you won't be hungry in the same way
where you're like
you'll claw someone's eyes out to you
know to be successful you've already
become successful
but i think like over time it's just
like you start going like okay i proved
it once now i have to do it again
at double the size and it's the same
thing that everyone says where it's like
what's the perfect amount of money it's
like two or three times whatever you
currently have
so if you exited for 30 this time you
got to exit for 90 next time
i it's just i it's just the way people
seem to work
god that's great um all right let's talk
about another one um
let's do all right i'll tell you this
one that i just did the other day
um and this one i actually think has
more reasons why it will fail than
why it will not fail why it will win
it's called tails
um let me find the url uh i don't even
know i remember
kaleswriters.com so i just i'm gonna uh
text it to you
so on the surface this has a lot of
things that i don't like
uh it could it's kind of like an iphone
game type of thing
um it's pretty hit driven
but i'm interested for in this for a
couple reasons the first
basically what it is is um it's this
technology where authors can upload
their books that they've already written
and they've made it so they can turn a
pre-written book into an interactive
story which is kind of interesting
um but i invested it for a couple
reasons one i've been
crazy fascinated with how authors can
make more money because i think books
traditionally are a horrible way to make
money off of someone who spends like
you know two years of their life writing
something like it's pretty shitty like
the difference like our friend jack
butcher pro probably makes more money
off his one course which impacts
probably 10 000 people
than a book that is read by a million
people which is pretty crazy when you
think
i think it's fascinating though because
like i'm writing a book right now
um i don't know if i'm even going to
release it i might just turn it into a
bunch of twitter
twitter tweet storms or blog posts or
something or make a podcast out of it
or that's what's interesting too is like
when you have all that content
you can take it and put it across all
the different channels right like build
it once
put it everywhere and monetize it across
all those different places
well there is legitimacy there's a
legitimacy around i know to hand someone
a book and say this is my story as i
want
you know to just to for you to
understand it and
you know it's like phil knight is like
the man because of shoe dog right
i agree so that that like i don't think
a book is going to go away but i think
that what you should do is write a book
as like a loss leader and then do all
this other stuff of which
tails is one of those things and the
reason why this business fascinated me
is because i think that romance novels
and
um anime and like entertainment like
that
for amongst young folks and particularly
women it's like one of the biggest
genres there is i mean it's just a rabid
fan base people love this stuff
i invested in this thing because i think
an author can charge like 30
for an interactive book and people will
read it a lot
and consume it a ton and there's a
company in china i'm always fascinated
with how the chinese
monetize content there's a company in
china called
well the american translation is just
called china literature
it's a 80 billion dollar publicly traded
company that does something just like
this in china and i'm fascinated with
how
authors can make more money i'm
fascinated with bringing uh the chinese
habits to america also the founder of
this company had invested like 800
000 or something like that of his own
money into the business and i was like
oh that's cool
like you're you're you're betting it i'm
interested so that's a recent one i did
but there's so many reasons why this can
fail um
it could be incredibly expensive to
acquire users i don't know if the users
are going to even stay for that long
and uh it could be a total hitch driven
business so this actually has a lot of
reasons why i can fail
and has a couple reasons why it could
work how the i think the hard part about
this though is that you've got to do all
this custom work on each
book like i get they've built the
framework but you've probably got to
have someone illustrate like a comic
almost for every single so that's the
technology that they've built it's like
they make it really easy for
yourself like you're the author to uh
make it interactive so that's like the
whole point that's like the technology
behind it but uh we'll see if they can
pull it off
it's been around for 12 months so it's a
working mvp
but uh tbd to see if this is gonna pull
uh they're gonna pull it off but
that's one thing i've just invested in
um all right your turn what do you got
what do you want to go over which one
so um we just we just uh we keep
investing in this business and it's a
lot of people don't understand it it's
called medi-map
and let's talk about any map so so up in
canada
yeah m-e-d-i-m-a-p so up in canada
uh we have socialized health care so the
government pays for it
and if you want to get um uh
care you can't just call any doctor and
get in
right so there's this whole system if
you want to see a dermatologist you have
to go
go to a you know general practitioner
get a referral it takes six months
in many ways it's better because anyone
who wants it gets health care
but the quality of care is probably
lower overall and
what it's resulted in is a system where
a lot of people don't have doctors and
you have to go to a walk-in clinic
and there's always walk-in clinics uh
you know all over canada
and um this this guy came to me like
five years ago
um because i had invested in a few other
healthcare businesses
and he goes hey i'm going to build this
business called medi-map
and basically you're going to be able to
go to the website and you're going to
see the wait times at every single
clinic in canada
and i was like well why would the who's
going to fill out the times right like
how are you going to
and he goes well i'm going to convince
the clinic owners that they want to be
on this site
and they should punch in you know the
wait times every hour
and i was like this seems insane like f
off i'm not going to invest right
comes back six months later and he goes
hey i've got 25
of all clinics in canada using this and
i'm like
well like how did you do that and it
turns out that
every single clinic every day gets
10 phone calls a minute and all the
phone calls are
is hey what's the wait time right
because everyone's trying to go where
the lowest wait time is
and so there's this huge incentive all
the clinic owners went oh my god i don't
have to have two
uh medical office assistants i can just
have one and that
that one can just punch in the wait time
so now this business has 86
of all medical walk-in clinics in canada
and every single one has
software installed wait time software
installed on their computers
so we've been investing in this business
it's been
uh you know losing money and we've been
building out this network
right and our thinking is once we have
the network there's a lot of really
interesting things we can do with the
network
and we've started expanding that so this
is it started as a venture investment
and then we ended up buying uh we now
have a like a control position in it
we're about to buy even more of it
and there's a lot of models globally for
this like zoc dock and other folks
and so now that we've got the network
established we have no competitors
even if someone raised a hundred million
bucks i don't know how you go out
and convince every clinic walking
walking clinic owner in canada to switch
to your software over ours
and so we're starting to now layer in
physiotherapy
naturopaths massage all sorts of other
services
and then we're also integrating into the
booking engines for all of these
and these people can pay to promote
their clinic and get more bookings and
stuff like that
so i'm super excited about it and it's
one of those businesses you might look
at and go you know i don't get it
where's the value
um but it's it's really really cool and
we're super excited about it well i'm
i'm on the site and i
i typed in my location i'm like oh wait
they're just uh uh in canada
it's been like vancouver or something i
did i just typed in vancouver okay so
uh so the way it works is i typed in
vancouver it says crossroads walk-in
clinic closes at 7 00 pm
as of right now they've got a 30-minute
wait time i can click and i can join
waitlist
and then i tell i select a uh what i'm
going to tell the doctor
and how i want to do the visit yada yada
yada so how do they make money
does the doctor say no no the doctor is
totally free to use
um and the doctor can i believe the
doctor can like
make a nicer profile so they can upload
their logo and stuff but we don't make
any money off of that
right so the idea is over time we make a
stronger and stronger network
and we can start to get directly like
like that one you can click to join the
waitlist immediately
and do that that's all free what we make
money on
is when you go and you say oh i want a
chiropractor
or i need to find a pharmacy and send in
a prescription or something
we can do referral agreements with all
those different clinics or pharmacies
but right as of right now we haven't
monetized it like this is like how many
people work there
uh like five or six it's very small oh
it's small and it looks like you got
like according to similar web you guys
are getting like
100 ish 50 to 100 ish thousand
uh visitors a month and the traffic is
mostly search and direct which is like
the greatest thing ever i mean that's
exactly what you'd want
um so i imagine you weren't spending it
it's a unique database right like
there's nowhere else you can go in
canada to get weightless times
and i can't i'm so you're probably
spending zero dollars on advertising is
that right
yeah we we've experimented a little bit
with it but we we spend very little at
this point so it's going back to like
understanding a moat and going like oh
this is like no one
can compete with this we spent the last
five years losing money and building the
network
and now it's like there's no way to
disrupt this and think of all the
different
things you can build in this i always
like to
say you know we like to buy airport
businesses and an airport is
you know there's one there's one airport
in the city if you want to go somewhere
and
fly you've got to go and sit in the
lobby for an hour and when you're
sitting in the lobby i'm going to try
and sell you a bunch of stuff
so i've got all the stalls and i can put
in a massage place and i can put in a
bookstore
somewhere to sell sandwiches whatever
and this is an airport business and
right now all the stalls are empty
and we're going to start monetizing it
and filling in all the stalls
that's a great analogy or a great story
where did you learn that one because
before you had new zealand businesses
which i like where
i made it up you made it up that's a
good one i like that one that's really
good
uh i'm going to steal that one uh so
like yeah medi-map i could see
how this is gonna work if i had to guess
i would say you've lost maybe six
million dollars on this so far
like uh yeah i think that's that's like
i think exactly how much we put in that
was a good guess
yeah uh i i'm just doing the math as to
you're not spending you're probably only
spending money on five or six salaries a
month
plus hosting which comes out to be
probably 85 to 95 000
a month you've done it for five years i
just made that number up so when it goes
back to if that was in the states
it would have been more competitive
right because canada
in canada healthcare is is not
privatized
not a lot of people are moving into it
and um
and there's just not a lot of venture
competition so if we're in the states we
would have had to raise 30 million bucks
move super fast be really aggressive but
we're able to kind of quietly
go out and do this and build the network
is zocdoc the nearest competitor
i mean zocdoc i think they're a
multi-billion dollar company is that
right
well they're only um they're only in the
states right
and so um you know i think they would be
illogical if they ever
if they were ever to move international
they'd be a logical acquirer of medi-map
and i think that
they're a great model right now we're
looking at it and going okay how do we
roll out the zockdoc playbook
or or find similar businesses elsewhere
i don't mean competitor but i mean it's
the zoc like the most
the nearest yeah the nearest comparable
zocdoc and that's a multi-billion dollar
company i think yeah that's pretty cool
um i'm looking
i would imagine the thing with with this
company is going to be backlinks and
what's interesting about you guys is
um i'm looking at i'm looking at now
you've got 750 referring domains which
is actually lower than i thought you've
got 7 100
backlinks but here's why it's kind of
actually interesting the way that you're
doing it
uh none of your all your traffic i
imagine is going to be search
like uh it's going to type it you're
going to someone's going to type in like
this clinic
wait time or this clinic phone number
and you're gonna show up like
don't call just click to see the wait
time but what's weird to me
is in canada do you guys have dot gov
websites is gov only an american thing
no we have that
it's like well it's like dove.gov.ca or
something but i think i think we
have.gov
the reason i'm asking is if this is if
most of your traffic is gonna come from
search you are gonna and all the
some of these clinics or i don't know
how the canadian uh i don't know how
your guys's healthcare system is
but if they're a government-sponsored or
government-owned healthcare clinic
i would imagine it would have a doc this
is the important distinction is they're
not government-owned they're
government-regulated
so the way it works is a clinic and
they're
they're challenging businesses because
the government basically dictates how
much you can charge per visit
and the government has to approve they
have to be run by a doctor
so it's basically like you can make
sliver thin margins
um and that's again why having someone
calling all the time
saving money on not having someone on
the phone all the time is massive for a
clinic owner
but here's what i'm getting at what i'm
getting is is this actually could be a
much bigger moat than i
realized because if you're getting a
bunch of gov websites linking back to
you
a dot gov url is worth the seos out
there will correct me but something like
a hundred
times more valuable than a dot-com and
so
i'm looking at this website if you could
talk uh if though if
i'm looking at your uh uh medi what's it
called uh medi-map i'm looking at the
the clinics if they all link back to you
and many of them are dot govs or dot
orgs or
or whatever or edus if they're like
you're going to have
a stupid amount of backlinks and you're
going to have
a significant advantage over anyone
because you're just going to crush on
search
because google uh any govs are
significantly high
higher rank than a dot uh dot com and a
dot edu so let's say you can get a
university clinic or something to refer
back to you
it's going to be actually quite amazing
i think and i would imagine this is the
type of company that's going to be
slow slow slow slow slow and then all of
a sudden it's it's just good it's
gonna be like oh like no one's gonna
catch us like nobody nobody gets this
and they go oh
you know there's always virtual care
like teledoc kind of stuff in canada
and i just keep saying like well when
you break your arm you're not gonna go
on teledoc right
that's a this is like a certainty like
death and taxes certainty is
people will always need physical doctors
and yeah
virtual will be 20 30 whatever but
it's uh it's not going away it's gonna
yeah you don't
you i'm not gonna call the doctor when i
have a kidney stone um so what
why don't you tell me about uh hustle
plus i don't know i don't wanna
i wanna i wanna i wanna do you wanna do
hustle plus or can we talk about
uh bakery and then cyber security and
then yeah yeah sure
okay totally i want to talk about
bakeries so you
is this the bakery that you've already
bought so no so i own i own a bakery
um i when i grew up my little brother
worked at a
local bakery just down the street from
our house and uh
uh yeah it was his first job and i used
to go there
all the time i got to know the owner um
i used to help him with his computer
when i was like 14.
and he maybe like four years ago said
hey look you know my parents are getting
old
i want to retire i'm thinking about
selling my business
and i was like well i don't know the
first thing about bakeries but he's got
a really good manager in place
and i don't want this to go to the wrong
people like i literally grew up going to
this bakery it's like an institution
in my city i love it uh and so i said
you know f it i'll buy it and so um i
bought it and now i own an italian
bakery in delhi
and it's actually a good little business
it's like that thing i always think back
to of like
if all this technology stuff fails and
all my stocks go to zero
i always have a bakery uh you know
that's that's not going to go anywhere
for 40 years
um but the idea with the bakery
so basically a couple months ago some
friends and i
did like a paleo diet challenge and i
felt amazing but i had crazy carb and
sugar cravings like i just wanted like a
a treat basically and when you're doing
paleo you're not allowed any grains
or sugar and there's hacks around that
right so you can be like okay i'm having
a
something that's sweetened with honey or
coconut flour
maple syrup or whatever those are all
total bs
right those all still spike your blood
sugar if you eat a spoonful of table
sugar versus a spoonful of
maple syrup like it's pretty much maybe
a little better but equally bad for you
and so i started researching otherwise
uh what do you mean i would have thought
that that was obvious
yeah i mean a lot of people think like i
talked to like uh
you know friends of mine and they're
like oh i gave my kids these these uh
really great snacks they're sweetened
with coconut sugar
and i'm just like dude sugar is sugar
and like if you wear a blood glucose
monitor
it's insane so anyway so i started
researching all these non-sugar
sweeteners and trying to think about how
to hack this
and make some snacks that i could eat
and
like stevia aspartame all the old all
that stuff
and i realized there's this whole new
generation of these so
a lot of the old ones they have like you
know stomach problems they cause
dysbiosis
or like stomach cramps and other stuff
but there's new ones that actually taste
really really good don't cause any blood
sugar spikes and are relatively healthy
like allulose and stevia and xylitol and
so i actually found a baker
i contracted the baker and i just said
hey like
make me five or six different things i
want to see if you know i can make
something interesting
and i started making these chocolate
chip cookies and
you know blueberry walnut cookies and
all this other stuff and they were
insanely good and so what i would do is
i would give them my friends and say
hey i bake these cookies let me know
what you think and they'd eat them and
say they're really good and i'd say well
there's no sugar
and they don't spike your blood sugar
and they're all healthy ingredients like
almond
almond flour and almond butter and stuff
and so
i started thinking about it and i was
like um you know everyone wants to be
healthy right now
and they're used to going to a bakery
and eating something unhealthy
given the option would they choose
something that's higher end and healthy
but still taste the same or better
so so like you know think about
mcdonald's mcdonald's was the standard
in the 90s
now there's chipotle if you're a little
more health-conscious you go to chipotle
and so i was like holy crap like you
know i don't really want to get in the
bakery business but this seems like a
great opportunity
and so i've been working on developing
all these recipes
and i've started um are you making like
god you're not
money so yeah so i literally i'm
literally starting a bakery it's gonna
be delivery only to start just as like a
beta test
and uh i'm calling it euphoria and
uh you know the idea is basically you
know tastes as good as a normal bakery
but it's actually really healthy for you
and i've worn a glucose monitor i've
done all these experiments
what are you using i'm not doing levels
i just use a dexcom
but uh anyway i'm i'm beta testing it
with a bunch of friends right now and
then in a couple weeks i'm
i'm launching it on doordash and going
to experiment but
it's just like one of those random you
know in like a business just like slaps
you in the face
yeah i want this for myself that's so
silly i can't believe this is so
this is very you this is it i find this
to be i'm
i'm very envious of you for doing this i
think this is so freaking cool
how much um did you employ this baker
full-time or what are you doing with
them
you just contract i found someone who
can work part-time
and uh i'm just doing that to start it's
very like 80 20 i'm like
how do i you know invest as little
amount of money as possible
and as little time as possible to do it
so i hired a designer
to do a logo on a simple website and
then i hired a baker to do the baking
and then a photographer did photograph
everything and that's it
what's your startup cost going to be uh
five five or ten grand probably maybe a
little more than that so
again this is probably a nothing but
it's one of those things like
at the very least no i just think it's
something
yeah it's definitely gonna be a
something i mean is it going to be like
the thing who knows it's definitely
going to be a thing
i mean like you i feel like you kind of
you if you screw this up you're kind of
an idiot
like yeah well it goes back to like if i
just called it a paleo bakery
even if it was unhealthy and shitty it
would do well right
and then you add on to that like that
you know the
all the glucose stuff and all the other
stuff that's getting hot right now i
think it's quite interesting
to summarize i think this is such a
great idea um
i think it will be fun i think that it
will make
life worth like little stuff like this
is life worth living
but maybe it could be immensely
profitable this is really smart i have a
friend named david hauser who started
grasshopper
grasshopper i know him grasshopper a lot
everyone knows dave he's a good guy
grasshopper was the software company
that he sold i think for 200 million
dollars
entirely bootstrapped it was basically
like a
small business phone service you pay 10
or something a month and you get a phone
line
um he started this thing called nut
butter is that what you know what's it
called
uh it's like a peanut butter pouch right
like a peanut butter thing um
and the business is so much harder than
a software company
but he's having so much fun and it seems
exciting
um i think i think like there's a
it's a double-edged sword right so um i
i used to always i used to always ask
people like you always get all these
tech people who make tons of money or
whatever and you're like well you know
what are you doing with your money like
are you starting any weird things like
you know i love dan gilbert which i
talked about in the last episode
um because he went how do i make my city
better
right it's like doing the fun stuff with
money and the way i look at this is like
hey i'm scratching an itch for something
i want
my friends might want but i make my city
better and it's just a cool you know
it's a cool
fun thing to play with right i think the
fun part of entrepreneurship
is going this should exist and making it
exist
um but at the same time like i've done
stupid stuff like that like i started a
pizza restaurant
and i lost eight hundred thousand 000
doing it it was a total disaster
i was getting phone calls like you know
we had a we had like an alcoholic
manager who was sleeping in the
restaurant
uh you know we had a sketchy landlord we
had like just
endless stress and [__] and so this
stuff is fun to appoint
and the key that i've learned is just
hiring amazing people so
i only like the beginning like this part
is fun but i gotta get out really quick
have you heard of the barber uh
motorsports
museum and racetrack no so there's this
guy
in alabama where is it uh somewhere in
alabama let's see it's in um
birmingham alabama but it's in the
country i think of birmingham alabama
his name is george barber he's probably
80 years old now
his father this guy's 80 and then his
father started a dairy company
so like farming dairy company just like
imagine like an alabama dairy company
that's what it was
sold it to dean foods for 500 million
dollars or something like that and they
were probably
breaking it in throughout the entire
50-year pro period in which they owned
it
he went with all the money he went and
started this thing called the barber
uh track and barber motorcycle and car
museum
and he has something like a thousand or
two thousand cars i believe it's the
largest collection of motorcycles in the
whole world
and he has this world-class track where
indy cars
um um like rolex sponsored formula one
uh races take place on this like
people from all over europe monaco all
come to birmingham
alabama to start and go or to go to this
uh barber race track
it's done so much for the community i
think he invested probably 50 million
dollars to make it because it's a
non-profit and you can look at how many
assets they have and how much cash they
have
and what their revenue is and it's
amazing and it's similar to your bakery
thing now a lot of people like you think
like oh how much
can a car museum and a track help the
community well it actually helps it a
ton because people all every
everyone go i'm going to go to barber
soon and take this lesson yada yada
and uh that's my version of a of a of a
bakery or saving detroit is i want to
start like a car museum and a car track
i think that's what i was starting
i was talking to a friend about this
yesterday but um do you remember like 10
or 15 years ago portland was suddenly
cool
right everyone's saying oh my god you
got to go to portland or whatever the
reason portland became cool
was because of the ace hotel right the
ace hotel was just kind of a funky hotel
and it had a photo booth and a good bar
in it and all this other stuff it was
kind of new
and i always think what's the ace hotel
that you can add to your own city
right like in victoria it's like what's
the thing that people come to see
and right now it's like uh you know some
twee english shops
and uh you know there's a beautiful
garden here
and a few other you know historical
things there's nothing cool
and so i've been thinking a lot about
this like is it like a crazy bar
or a music venue or a hotel or something
like that
but what's the debt what makes this
place the destination because i think
something as simple as that can change
an entire city um
i don't know what the answer is but that
kind of stuff is really interesting to
me
earlier you brought up henry singleton i
like henry singleton i've read this
really good book called the outsiders i
know that's probably your bible is that
right
i love that book okay so the outsiders
um it's a great book it's about
12 ceos who are quote outsiders the the
commonalities
is they're like kind of quiet they're
kind of afraid of the press
they are typically in locations like
nebraska or
[Music]
somewhere not silicon valley or new york
and they just get
pretty good results but they get it
every single year for like 50 years
so they'll like grow something by like
20 or 15
but they do it every year for so long
that by year
20 30 40 it's like oh my gosh they're
warren buffett they're henry singleton
yada yada
who is this guy so yeah and the idea is
basically that they're capital
allocators which is kind of a weird
nerdy term but it basically just means
they they're really good at putting
their money into buckets where they can
make a lot more of it
versus investing in the wrong thing and
what a lot of people miss is
you can have the most innovative ceo in
the world but if they misallocate their
dollars and they put it into
you know low return r d versus high
return
acquisitions or whatever you can have a
very bad result despite being very
innovative and a great
uh leader and manager um so henry
singleton is like
everyone thinks warren buffett's the
greatest investor of all time
henry singleton um you know i think he
died in the 80s
but i'm pretty sure he actually has a
better record than warren buffett
and nobody really knows his name they
only know it because of the outsiders
there's been one other book written
about him but he basically got into
these very
niche very technical fields where they
would do
like um it'd be like navigation
equipment that's on like a
you know a fighter jet or random little
like diodes for
for circuitry and all this kind of stuff
but you'd find these niches where they
could kind of
own it or have a very dominant position
in it what's
there's this very simple um kind of way
of thinking about
investing and his whole thing was when
the market is overvalued and crazy
that's a great time to issue stock and
to sell things
and when the market is undervalued you
want to be
buying not only buying back your own
company so if you don't own your entire
company you want to go and you know buy
back more stock
and you want to be investing then and so
that approach
is you know it's very simple it doesn't
sound like rocket science
but i think it's a really important
thing for people to be thinking about
right now
and i think now is a great time to be
scanning your portfolio
or businesses and going how can i um
how can i basically take advantage of
valuations right now
and either you know issue stock or use
my stock in my business to go buy stuff
or just wait for opportunities because
right now it's like
a crazy seller's market which is
shockingly the hardest part
is the not doing anything um so
in time like you have far more
perspective than this you're
uh more successful than i am and you're
a couple years older than i am so you
are
just a little everything that i am
interested in you are but more
how are you and other people who you've
met
that that buy into this how do you guys
just sit and chill
uh how do you not do new stuff because i
say to myself all the time i'm gonna
i'm not gonna like pounce on x y and z i
gotta wait i gotta wait i gotta wait
i get so antsy and i can't like it's i
it's hard well there's a reason i'm
starting a
sugar-free bakery right like this that's
the stuff that's honestly my
my secret to not doing too much
is i distract myself um and you know
before covet i'd be distracting myself
with
sports and you know playing uh bridge
and hanging out with friends and going
on walks and stuff
now it's starting businesses and they're
really small little businesses they're
like hobby businesses
um you know it's like um me just kind of
playing with 10 or 20 000 but it's
enough to keep me distracted and happy
and active and feel like i'm doing
something but in reality i'm sitting on
my hands and building up cash
and what like you so
you still have enough time to do that
and do the we commerce thing which
for those who don't know andrew i don't
know how you describe it if you started
it which
you owned it i don't know what the right
terminology is but you have this thing
that went public and is
currently like i don't know what it is
today but like many hundreds of millions
of dollars in market cap
yeah we started a business about 10
years ago we met the founder
of shopify and at the time we were
running a design agency and he said hey
we want to launch
themes on our platform we want people to
be able to sign up and have
different designs they can choose from
and we'll let you guys sell
these themes on the platform for you
know 150 to 250
and so we were kind of thinking like hey
it's a small little canadian company
these guys seem nice let's do it
and uh we started doing it and shopify
just grew into a behemoth
and we rode the whale and did really
well and we actually sold the business
in 2013.
we didn't realize how big shopify would
get and then we bought the business back
in 2019
um we did a bunch of back for more than
you sold it
way more yeah think it was five five
times
six times so we bought it back we
we and we said like we you know we're
just making a big bet we think shopify
is going to get a hell of a lot bigger
and we made a holding company called we
commerce and we started buying
businesses
and kind of building a mini version of
tiny um
within the shopify ecosystem and then we
took it public in december
and we're listed on the tsx venture
exchange up in canada
and uh as of right now i don't know if
this is in canadian dollars or american
but it's 663 million dollar market cap
i think that's yeah i think canadian
that's canadian so 600
663 canadian dollars so it's pretty big
um
how but i mean like you're saying you're
like just sitting there not doing
anything just waiting waiting waiting it
seems like you're doing something
well i mean i'm we started this podcast
by me saying
i'm stressed out and busy right so i
think
i i don't want anyone to get the wrong
idea that you know
it's more i'm filling my time when i
have it
by distracting myself with this other
stuff and that all of the things i'm
focused on right now for the most part
like while i'm looking at buying
businesses everything's so overpriced
that i don't want to make a swing on the
wrong thing
so i'm filling the rest of my time with
other things
and one of those things is not email you
told me the other day that you um
for the first time ever which is
actually shocking to me this first time
ever
you've hired someone or you've asked
your assistant to
completely manage your email and you
said something like
this is the first day i've tried it tbd
if it actually works
is it working and what are you doing
yeah so i'm doing i'm doing two things
that are kind of interesting
so um one i fully delegated my email to
my assistant
so um i get i i've started getting over
the last couple years like
200 or 300 emails a day and
honestly it was just making me kind of
miserable like it was just i've tried
all the best practices and
we even built a company called mailman
that basically like slows down your
email and
and does do not disturb on it and stuff
but it just wasn't enough
and i hit my breaking point a couple
weeks ago i was just spending like five
hours a day doing email
and i set up tech support software i
piped my email into it
and i have my assistant and then we have
another
assistant we have in the philippines and
they basically monitor the email
and they have a set of rules so i wrote
out like if someone
asks me to sign a document send it to
this person on our legal team
they'll review it and then if they say
yes you can sign it
as long as it's below this amount um if
someone requests an interview
go and look at the podcast see how many
vol
downloads it gets and if it's above this
you can schedule it or whatever
and so i made like 10 of these rules and
now i'm getting like 20 emails a day
because the only ones that come through
to me
are the ones where it's a friend asking
me a direct question or it's one of our
ceos or you know a go no go on an
investment
and so it just freed me up by like two
or three hours and it's a classic
example of like
the e-myth kind of where you're like you
know desperately doing all this stuff
that you don't really need to be doing
because you've always done it
um so that's been awesome what's up and
then e
i don't know what the e-myth is oh you
don't know that book i've i
i've seen it i i don't know what the
myth is i've never actually read it
the e-myth the entrepreneur myth i think
it is but um
i think that's the best i thought see i
always thought it meant electronic
like it no it's it's an amazingly badly
written book but it's a very important
message
it was like transformational for me like
12 years ago and the idea is basically
um when people start businesses they
don't build systems and they don't
delegate
right so uh the person who loves baking
starts a bakery and then before they
know it they're staying up until two
baking and then they wake up at seven in
the morning to mop the floor
and then they're behind the tail all day
they're miserable they're stressed and
they
thought they were creating this utopian
business that they wanted
and in reality it just sucks and they're
miserable and the reason it sucks and
they're miserable is because
they don't delegate they don't build
process they don't hire people
when they do hire people they don't give
them a chance and so it's all about how
to delegate
got it okay and what were you saying
about the email thing
so and then the other thing i did um
which has been really fun
um i i used to like i used to do this
myself so i used to cold email
i still do it actually i still cold
email entrepreneurs that i think are
really cool and i want to meet
or ask them questions and like five
years ago i started getting emails from
young entrepreneurs saying hey can you
look at my startup or can you give me an
opinion on this
and i used to write really thoughtful
responses and then as i got more email
i just couldn't respond and i felt
really really guilty about this 100
i'd like to delete it sometimes i just
like delete and other times i'd be like
one line response and i'd be like [__]
they think i'm an [__]
100 same dude i've done that with some
people and then i've eventually become
friends with them
and you know how like on twitter you can
see like you recognize people's
thumbnail over and over there's this one
guy the other day that i've seen him
talk to me all the time
and then i've been hanging out with this
other person like through a friend of a
friend like three different times now
and i knew his name and i'm like
[__] you're the guy i've been ignoring
yeah i'm so
sorry man i'm so sorry i i didn't
realize it so anyway i do the same thing
and it kills me
when you never know who they're gonna
become or they could have this great
idea if you just talk to them and get on
the phone
and so um what i ended up doing i
realized i was actually doing myself a
disservice by responding because i just
say like
you know this is too long write me a
shorter you know question or whatever it
is you know the douchey
like yeah i'm too busy stuff like that
you know what you're asking so now i
write them back i have a template or my
assistant writes them back and just says
hey um i don't respond to these via
email
what i like to do is i do an ama ask me
anything every month
and if you if you can afford to donate
to charity
um you know just as a way of you know
paying it forward or whatever
and so if someone's rich if someone has
a big company already i'm like hey go
donate some money
if they're a first-time entrepreneur we
don't expect them to and then chris and
i just do a monthly ama
and then everyone gets to enjoy the
answer we do so
it's dude so it's been crazy so we we've
already donated 58
000 to charity from this so we basically
whatever the community donates we double
it and then we donate it to a local
charity
so for we've donated 58k half of which
came from
people who donated and then uh it's
probably saved me two or three hours a
month i'm just not responding to these
emails
so it's like a really great hack should
i copy that i think that's great
totally yeah did you make that up uh
yeah i think we made it up
that's wonderful that is such a good
idea where did you send the 56k to
have you picked your thing yeah we did
one one was like a uh it's called
bridges for women i think
i think it was um and it's for women
that are transitioning out of abusive
households
and then the other one was a gym a local
gym some guys set up a gym for
uh handicapped people because there's no
equipment for handicapped people in town
and so it's somewhere you can go and
work out if you're you know
uh paraplegic or something
what's the most amount of money you've
ever donated
or given can you reveal that uh
i i've given away probably like three or
four million bucks i think
so wow that's crazy isn't it
it's really um it's it's really crazy
and i'm just kind of learning
i'm learning i'm going like how what's
the most effective thing to do
because there's everything from like
local feel good right where
you can help a small number of people
but you know you're making their life 10
better but you're not saving a life
versus if you put the money into like
malaria medication or bed nets or that
sort of thing
in the third world um you know i think
that's what i'm kind of debating right
now is how to how to be most effective
with my altruism
i can't believe though like you've given
away that much money that's a huge
amount i've like
i haven't done really much of anything
um and i want to
um the way i started was i um i just
started doing
um donating to science so i'd be like as
i was researching
different medical things i'd be like oh
this researcher is really cool
i'm going to start donating monthly and
i just fund their work
and then over time i just put more and
more into it
um and then you know over the last year
i started the tiny foundation
if you've seen that but about a year ago
i started doing this thing where i would
just find people who i thought were
smart
in fields that i thought were important
and i'd say here's a hundred to three
hundred thousand dollars
you choose where it goes so you donate
it it can go to your own research
it can go to a friend's anything you
think is important and it just saves me
from having to do all the
diligence and work so i'm looking at it
now
even your foundation website looks
pretty badass which is awesome
yeah we hired some really awesome
designers for that yeah it looks really
good so for this
um wow besides just like
doing good uh which is like the most
important thing but let's just be real
is there anything that you're getting
out of this
um i mean what i get out of it is other
than feeling good
well for example so i don't i don't
think i've talked about on here but
um i had acid reflux like horrible acid
reflux for
eight years and uh i started researching
it and i read
tons of research about it and i was like
holy crap if you get esophageal cancer
you die
like there's literally no treatment and
so i actually one of the things i'm
funding is a
esophageal cancer research center at ubc
and is you know so you could argue maybe
i'm trying to save myself in the future
maybe if i get this um but other than
that it's a great way to meet
interesting people as well right like
i've met all sorts of amazing
researchers and um doctors and all sorts
of other stuff as a result
but no i mean it's just i'm trying to
figure out how to convert
money into something other than more
money
and more you know more problems
um last topic something i want to ask
you about
i don't i think it was a friend i forget
who nick or my friend nick ray or i
don't know who i forget who
said something about how one time you
bought
a charity dinner or charity lunch with
uh
ackman bill ackman um and
at the time everyone like made fun of
you like who's this idiot from canada
that would spend 50 000
on a lunch i mean they don't realize
that that money actually goes to a
charity as well
but they're like oh my gosh like this is
so stupid yada yada yada
turns out you actually became friends
with
bill i think uh i don't know him but i'm
gonna call him bill like i do
and you guys have like done business
together and i'm sure you've made that
money back
many times over but you have this
interesting way of networking you have
this interesting way of getting your
foot in the door
one time on this podcast you told a
story about warren buffett
you've told you've told me uh a couple
people that you've been hanging out with
like in like you've had you're like oh
my gosh i just did a zoom with x y and z
and they're like
pretty big deal people what is your
whole thing
about networking i mean you're just
talking about cold emailing what
what you have this weird philosophy
about this yeah so
i'm gonna first to start with i think
networking is really fun if you're an
extrovert
and i'm an extreme extrovert right so
when i feel depressed or sad i want to
be around people
i want to share my problems i want to
connect with people right so so i by
default do this
um and i would say like starting about
15 years ago
um i just started i started seeing all
these interesting people
on the internet and going wow they seem
amazing like i want to do business with
them i want to become friends with them
and specifically there's all these
people in new york
who are big tumblr users who just seem
super cool you know the founders of
collegehumor and vimeo and
all those people and so i started uh i
started doing a couple things one of
them was
i never eat alone so pre-covered i'd
always have lunch with somebody
usually locally and i'd almost always do
at least one call with a random person
who i either haven't met or i'm just
building a relationship with even if
it's like 30 minutes first thing in the
morning
the other thing i did is i started
paying to be in the right room
so i remember telling someone 10 years
ago
i wasn't doing super well right i maybe
was doing
15 20k a month of revenue uh or
something like that
and i paid 10 000 to go to the ted
conference
and all my friends were like what the
hell are you thinking you're spending
all this money on this
when i went to the te i have this whole
thing about paying to be in the right
room right so
um when you go to ted it's like a secret
club if you get into ted
every single person that's there is
someone interesting
um and at the very least they've paid a
lot of money to be there so they're
legit
and being in the room if you're in the
room everyone goes oh they're legit too
and so i was this like twerp with this
tiny little business
and i'm talking to al gore and the
founders of google
and you know all these amazing people
and just being in a room with those
people you naturally over the course of
going
consistently for years you end up
meeting all these amazing
people and making connections you end up
doing business with them
and so my doing that just going to ted
and
probably spending 30k on on tickets for
three years
i think it ended up resulting in 10 or
20 million dollars of
revenue for my various businesses and so
i'm a big fan of doing that the other
thing i like to do
is host events so i try and bring
someone really interesting to town in
victoria
and then i invite a whole bunch of other
people who i think are interesting
and then by doing that you know you've
you've basically made
this collection of people where you're
the host and you know you're kind of in
charge of
of the whole group and you get to meet
the speaker and other stuff and so
an example of that is i thought uh shane
parish from farnam street was super
interesting and brought him out to do a
speaking event
brought out all my favorite people from
victoria and elsewhere
and i ended up becoming friends with
shane and now
shane is an investor with us and we've
done a whole bunch of deals and he's a
good friend
and so um i think like one of the
uh one of the there's just one of the
things no one recognizes is there's
an insane amount of optionality and
upside and just knowing great people
both personally you know you make great
friends but when you have a problem or
you want to build a business or you need
investors
being able to call a bunch of amazing
people is the ultimate hack
and so yeah that same thing happened
with bill i went into
that charity lunch you know actually
looking at it as
like a kind of a diligence thing i had
invested in his
uh his company and i was going well if i
don't like him i'll sell it and if i
like
hold on hey yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
don't know if he had you invested
i had like five million dollars five
million dollars invested in his
uh holding company pershing square
holdings personally yeah
yeah and i don't do like a tough guy i
mean
he's not he's not a tech guy like what i
had no i honestly didn't really think of
it as like oh this is super strategic
he's a really smart investor this was in
2017 i think or 2016. and
how many that was a four or five that
was five years ago so you were like what
31 yeah 31 or so um
uh 5 million no matter what is a lot of
money but
at 31 that must have been a significant
amount of your of your
wealth um it is my largest investment
outside of
the tech businesses and you put it all
in that
in his fund well i saw it was basically
like
bill bill had a series of um
challenging investments and so his stock
traded way down
and when i looked at it i was like okay
i can buy a dollar of amazing stock
so so it's really simple it's a holding
company that owned about 10
stocks and if you looked at the stocks
it was like lowe's
howard hughes corp which is like a real
estate business chipotle like really
good blue chip businesses
and for every dollar of stock that was
sitting in the holding company
you could buy it for 65 cents because
the stock had traded down so much so it
was like buying a dollar for 65 cents so
i didn't necessarily think bill was a
you know genius i thought he was a very
smart investor
i just thought it was a very cheap stock
and so i bought it and then when i saw
this charity lunch come up i was like oh
sweet i can like
grill this guy and see if i like him and
the upside is
uh 57 grand and the upside is
he's just a really smart investor and
maybe i can learn something from him but
he doesn't invest in tech or at least i
didn't know he did so i had no
like i didn't think i'd be doing
business with them it was like a pinch
me moment when
you know we ended up investing in stuff
together um
what happened to the the stock uh it
went up a lot
uh it went up it doubled or more tripled
or something since i bought it so it's
it's done really well
it's it's tripled so the 5 million went
to 15 in a matter of six years
yeah i i think i think i actually it
might have been 2018
it's either 2017 or 2018 i had lunch
over the last over the last few few
years it traded way up
he's done he's done amazingly well i
don't know if you saw i think you guys
talked about it on the pod but
he had a bet where he invested 25
million and it turned into 2.7 billion
and that was in that that that holding
company that i'm an investor in
oh my gosh that is so funny um
um so back to the networking
i got distracted the pay the payoff is
that's so cool
i mean obviously for business it's great
you surround i i really believe you're
you're the sum of the five or ten of you
know best friends or most interesting
people around you
so i think it influences you really
positively um
but the cool thing that that's happened
is now it compounds
so now i don't actually do cold emails
very often
i don't really like consciously network
i just naturally every week or two
i get introduced to someone really
interesting and so now it's this like
i planted the garden and now i'm
enjoying the fruits from it
my issue is i don't really want to talk
to people like that much
uh like you and i text message um and
i'm okay with text
like i'll text like there's like 10
people who i'll text
uh you're one of them it's like other
than that like i really don't want to
talk to anyone
and it kind of actually stresses me out
because i don't
it doesn't trust me out because in one
regard it doesn't trust me because i
don't want to talk to people
like i i really only want like a small
group and i only want to be with them
um and like you're you're one of those
people we're all well i'll just text you
and be like hey do you see the new
911 get released or like we just
[__] right we don't we don't talk
about work we just talk about
uh just bought this car does this is
this check out this video listen to it
it's cool
um but then i feel left out because i'm
like i'm
like sean does this a lot sean networks
with everyone and he gets access to all
this cool stuff
and i'm like i want that access but i
don't want to spend the time talking to
these people because i just get nervous
or
you have the ultimate you have the
ultimate hack though which is you
you have this platform right i've
started realizing this too there's a
reason i come on i have a lot of fun
talking to you guys
but at the same time there's 10 000
people listening
and a whole bunch of them are super
fascinating and they're going to email
both of us and say
hey dude i'd love to do something with
you or whatever so we just bypassed
you know 10 the problem with networking
is you do
five boring calls and then one amazing
one right so you're constantly talking
to people you don't necessarily want to
talk to
where they don't turn out to be that
interesting when you think they will be
um but it's worth it because there's a
diamond in the rough and i think
podcasting is interesting because
it lets you you basically have like
10 000 people who kind of learn what
you're about and they can either decide
if they like you or not and if they opt
in and they like you
you've already pre you've pre-like sold
them almost right like when i get on the
phone with someone fresh
i actually tell a story about like this
is how i started and this is my company
and this is what we do and
it's all kind of it's not a sales pitch
but it's really like hey here's who i am
and you can just bypass all of that via
podcast or something
yeah i i hear you and i what i usually
when i talk to people i'll be like
i'll be like hey i don't want to be
pretentious or anything but like do you
know who i am
um yeah because like i can save us time
and i won't like do the spiel
uh they're like oh i listen to the
podcast i'm like sick i'm not gonna tell
you anything
what's going on how are you um the other
day i had this guy named michael loeb do
you know who michael loeb is
yeah he um he has an incubator like a
big big incubator his house
is the house in billions the hamptons
house yeah so
i like this guy i don't know him other
than the few minutes that i just talked
to him but i
knew about him and i actually admire
what i read about him he
started this thing called synapse i
think which he sold
to meredith some or time magazine
for uh 800 million dollars then with
that money he started priceline
uh he started with this guy named jay
walker and i think they sold that for
billions of dollars and i think it was
the fastest
time anyone has ever made a billion
dollars like from
launch to like the sale or the the
public
markets it was like uh like a year or
something like stupidly crazy
he got made all of his money there
bought this huge house in the hamptons
which if you watch
the tv show billions axelrod bobby
axelrod buys this house for like a
hundred million dollars like something
crazy and it's
like the whole point is it's supposed to
be like the the representation of greed
and and too much money and that's the
house that he buys well that's michael
loeb's house
and a couple years ago he there was this
party
or a charity actually a charity event
and they raised like 350 000
for this event but one of his sons uh
has a friend over who gets drunk and
says something smart to him so michael
punches him in the face
and gets arrested so he's got this if
you google michael loeb arrested you'll
see his mug shot
he's got like a white t-shirt on like
they could clearly like pulled him out
of bed
so anyway and they found out that you
know michael loeb is like this rich guy
so the dad of the son probably sued him
yada yada yada well anyway
he heard he didn't but one of his
assistants someone
must make a list of every young
entrepreneur who sold the company
and they send you this email from
michael and it's like hey
i'm michael loeb i'm such a fan um and
like
i know this guy's like 60 something
years old
i'm like i don't think this is you but
that's cool like it's your assistant
and he goes hey um let's talk so i
talked to him and i could tell he
doesn't know who i am and
it's it's no big deal he wasn't he it
wasn't like a disrespect or anything
but uh i was honored that he even
reached out or his people did
and he's like so i'm thinking about
hosting this event for entrepreneurs
are are you interested in coming i'm
like dude
i'm not going to be pretentious here i'm
sorry if i come off that way but
like you're talking to like the guy uh i
host these things called hustle con
i do this i got this podcast thing i've
got this email
thing like i've got your target
demographic
and he goes yeah well like i'm wanting
to host an event at my house have you
seen have you heard of my house like
yeah i've heard of your house obviously
i've heard of your house it's like the
house
and i'm trying to convince him now to
make me a co-host and i don't think he's
gonna make me a co-host but i hope he'll
invite me to come to his house in the
hamptons where he wants to have like 50
or 100 young entrepreneurs
and i have a feeling what this guy does
is he owns this thing called loeb
enterprises and i think he owns 100 of
it and it's very much like tiny
where they invest a small sum of money
into interesting ideas
and they'll co-own the business with the
entrepreneur starting it
um or they'll own it wholly and give the
entrepreneur a salary
and they build up these companies and
then they eventually sell them and
they've had some great success they
built up
i think this thing called script relief
uh did a hundred million a year in
profit
um they built up a bunch of interesting
things but
related to networking that's my
networking story
and maybe i'll be hanging out with
michael loeb and whoever he hangs out
with i don't know who he hangs out so
cool
i want to invite to that event that
sounds awesome we got we got introduced
to him when we were in new york last
time so chris and i go to his office
and uh he's like an old school almost
like almost like a car salesman right
like we sit down
and he's like hi guys i'm michael loeb
and uh
he pulls out a slide deck but it's not
on a screen it's literally a printed
slide deck and he
this is goes story he has no idea who i
am he just like
goes through this slide deck and he
starts going line by line about it
and uh i i i i thought it was really
charming and he seemed like a cool guy
but it was crazy like he definitely has
like a shtick and
he has like a system for this stuff um
and
it was really interesting because his
house is like crazy
right like i haven't been to it but i've
seen photos and you know watched around
billions
you go to his office and you're like oh
it's just like a new york office right
random office it's like chaos there's
like
you know weird desks everywhere and like
shitty chairs
and disgusting it's funny like seeing
um you know these in new york you can be
the richest person in the world but it's
like you still have to ride the subway
you're still you still you still have a
cramped office all this other stuff it's
funny
yes i saw he videoed me and i could see
in his office and it looked like
uh all of his employees were at home
except for his crew and he clearly had
like this
very stereotypical like i didn't
actually see this woman but this is like
i could kind of tell that this person
was in the background this very typical
like
50 year old secretary who's had for like
30 years
who like i can just imagine her with her
flats and like dress on handing him
coffee and like she's this nice
lady i just like everything about him
fit this stereotype and frankly i loved
it i think this guy is incredibly
interesting
uh is loeb enterprises is that i think
they're really legit they've
created a couple really interesting
things yeah i mean it's very legit and
it's one of those things where you
you go in and he's like oh we've got you
know this company and this company and
this company and you know one of them
sends wine direct you know direct mail
wine and the other one does like
receipts and you take a photo of your
receipt and send it and
you're kind of going like i don't know
what the bs
is versus what the big businesses are
like they throw a lot of spaghetti
against the wall
and they incubate a lot of businesses
and like you said they have an amazing
track record of making some of these big
businesses
um but uh but yeah he's he's a total
character
yes that guy is crazy interesting i'm so
happy i got to talk to that guy
um i i have another meeting with us
folks um
um and i'm looking forward to talking to
him and
if i host that dinner or even if i get
to attend the dinner and he lets me
invite people
i'm gonna invite you because um inviting
you and a few other people that's like
maybe that's like how i'm gonna look
legit to this person um
super fascinating
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to
travel never looking back
[Music]
uh